hey everyone how's it going my name is
Mirko and welcome to my channel where we
talk about tech career and life so today
we're going to be talking about what I
think is the most important skill in
software engineering I'm making this
video because I really was just someone
told me this when I was starting off as
a software engineer because I think it
could have better directed my efforts
and given me some direction and maybe
for you this will also get rid of some
impostor syndrome anyways I'm gonna
change it up and tell you what I think
it is from the get-go also because I
feel a little bit guilty from the
clickbait title well compare it to the
two skills that other people think are
the most important and in the process
help you to understand where I'm coming
from and why I think the way that I do
so without further ado drum roll please
I think the most important skill in
software engineering is learning how to
learn yes it is and I know this sounds a
little bit like the whole if you could
have three wishes what would it be
answer my first wish would be to have
infinite wishes it also sounds like
something that people already know how
to do naturally but hear me out say yes
learning how to learn is something that
you already know how to do but to an
extent because when we're thinking about
learning stuff with regards to software
engineering it's not necessarily an easy
task it's easy to procrastinate the
unmotivated get stuck or just get
completely lost
honing this skill allows you to whip
past any of those blockers and unlocks
so much potential in you to climb any
mountain ahead and learn whatever you
like so yes my answer is a little bit of
a I would have infinite wishes kind of
thing because duh it's like the best
choice anyway some people might disagree
with me on the most important skill in
software engineering and there is a lot
of conflicting advice on the internet
but I mean in reality software
engineering just requires a lot of
different skills in order to do the job
well the first of which people might
argue are technical skills I think this
actually encompasses a general group of
a lot of skills like the ability to
write well structured and testable code
or design resilient and extensible
architecture or it's to have a firm
grasp on whatever technology is the new
it's that year so yeah I think a lot of
people on the internet might argue that
this is the most important one and I'm
not saying the technical skills aren't
an important skill in fact they're kind
of vital when you're writing code but I
just don't think it's the most important
for one technologies are always changing
all the freaking time yes at the end of
the day technical skills enable
programmers to write code that produce
results but rarely are we ever writing
the same kind of code every five years
nor are we even writing the same
programs every single day new languages
frameworks architectures tools are being
born and reinvented every single year so
it's true that software engineers need
to stay up-to-date with new technologies
in order to unlock potential and stay
relevant so I think it's less about the
technology itself and more about
learning what you don't know that's more
important secondly while we're on the
topic of technical skills
no one knows everything honestly it
often feels like there's this God level
of coder or programmer and that we're
trying to achieve but because of the
fact that tech is always changing nice
to mention there's literally so much to
learn I don't think it's realistic nor
healthy to solely strive towards
technical mastery and technical skills
alone don't make you a great software
engineer anyways I think that the tech
industry is overvalued coding skills for
quite some time now but it has to exist
with an aptitude of communication and
empathy in order for those technical
skills to be worthwhile and valuable so
compared to technical skills I think
learning how to learn is a more
worthwhile skill because working on this
actually allows you to attain those
technical skills in an easier and
efficient way because when you're
learning how to learn a new technology
you'll get really good at reading
documentation and you just get really
good at getting a grasp on any
technology even if there isn't a paved
road of beautiful tutorials in front of
you which like let's face it is about
90% of learning a new technology and
speaking of learning how to learn and
technical skills the sponsor for today's
video is brilliant they're a website
that has a bunch of courses in
Sciences their courses are all
interactive breaking down complex topics
with great visuals teaching you how to
think and learn why not take a course on
brilliant and start your journey and
learning how to learn today by going to
brilliant org slash hello my you go and
sign up for free and the first 200
people to go to that link will get 20%
off of the annual premium subscription
the link is also in the description box
down below and brilliant thank you for
sponsoring now let's get back to the
video all right so we talked about
technical skills now let's go to what
some would consider the opposite end of
the spectrum communication skills now I
actually think that the industry is
starting to embrace this as the most
important skill after all no one wants
to work with a brilliant jerk who might
be great at coding but it's totally
unpleasant to work with I know I don't
and I think communication skills are
harder to teach than technical skills so
a lot of companies are introducing or
have had behavioral style interviews in
order to gauge a candidate's
communication abilities and again I'm
not saying the communication skills
aren't important doing it well and able
smooth and efficient execution as well
as improving yours and others quality of
life at work and it's something that I
think everyone should always be working
on as a skill but in order to
communicate well you have to be good at
learning how to communicate well because
in reality no one is perfect at it I
don't even think a concept of perfection
exists when we're talking about this
it's more of an art than a science and
different communities and settings have
different standards on what good
communication is I mean just think of
all the cultural and language
differences there are in communication
we're all constantly learning on how to
be good communicators in lots of
different settings all the while society
is changing and we're changing how we
communicate and what we communicate with
and what words we use so learning how to
learn here wins again by honing that
skill you learn how to receive feedback
about your communication style really
well and you also learn how to ask for
feedback you also learn how to deal with
complex emotions that
arise when working with other people so
yeah I think learning how to learn is
the most important software engineering
skill it's like a superpower and in the
end I think it all comes back down to
being a lifelong learner I software
engineers our careers require us to
learn lots of different things so honing
that skill getting good at learning is
really worthwhile anyways that's it for
this video hope you enjoyed it leave a
comment down below for what you think is
the most important skill for software
engineers make sure to hit that
subscribe button and notification bell
to get notified when my videos go live
and I will see you next time
bye